would you rather live with your parents
for the rest of your life or always have
to use toilet paper as napkins okay this
thing the toilet always use toilet paper
as napkins I mean if I can fold a piece
of toilet paper and make it look pretty
impressive yeah
origami that stuff now I've been um yeah
there's been days when I've I've been on
the TP exclusively
um I mean it it really breaks apart but
I mean at the end of the day I'm not I'm
not sleeping in my parents basement yeah
my parents don't even have a basement
those parents aren't together
which one would get me I don't want them
to have to fight all over again who am I
going to live with you made this very
complicated uh yeah toilet paper